i'm dave rubin and we've got another
friday round table extravaganza for you
today i'm joined by the host of the
jesse kelly show jessie kelly how'd he
figure that out and hosts of the brand
new blaze tv show you are here elijah
schaefer and sydney watson welcome to
the reuben report guys
thanks for having us
no it's an honor for you to have me
indeed it is i am glad to have you guys
i have to say right up top i was going
to start by talking a little bit about
internet censorship and then i don't
know what the hell happened but we
normally live stream this thing and uh
we are having problems so this is this
is taped so i guess my first question to
all of you is do the internet lords have
it out for us jesse
well they definitely have it out for us
but uh the truth is that our our sheer
magnetism is way more powerful than any
internet streaming service out there
could ever be so at some point in time
everyone on this video is going to be
banned completely from the internet but
we'll just come up with something else
to do
that's the plan i just found out that
you're six foot eight so you could have
a nba career in front of you
uh yeah i could if i could jump over a
piece of paper or run very fast at all
so i think i'll just kind of stand on
the sidelines and wave a towel look you
still make millions doing that i'm fine
with it yeah pretty good sydney uh you
and elijah have this new show you guys
have already just in a couple weeks you
got like a couple strikes from youtube
or you were taken down from youtube then
you were back on youtube
what do you make of this whole thing
yeah so our lovely elijah loves to say
very true but uh inflammatory things
that definitely piss off youtube so we
definitely ended up with two strikes but
then they were subsequently removed
elijah can totally fill you in on what
actually happened because he knows this
a little bit better than i do um
honestly
i think we're at a point where
the censorship is just getting to a
an extreme level i think that you know
similar to what jesse has to say about
this they just want us go on i mean if
you're counter narrative you're counter
to what they want you to think you're
they're you're not someone that they
want around so i i don't know elijah how
long do you think our show's gonna last
on a serious note i don't know i know
that they've they've gotten down to
telling me that i'm not even allowed to
call horse dewormer anything else but
the i word which i'm trying to figure
out i feel like a four-year-old that's
like we don't say the c word baby and
and i think the ridiculousness of all
this is is it's like the point of what
we're all trying to say is not getting
lost in fact the censorship is making
the point of what we're intending
actually more solidified because the
more that we say this stuff is important
and the more that we're told we're not
allowed to say it the more important
people realize it is and i think it's
kind of funny because when you use
euphemisms to skirt around sensors and
use newspeak to get around you know this
communist chinese firewall this digital
berlin barrier you know people go wait
what the hell is the i word and then it
makes them question and then it brings
them deeper down the rabbit hole and i
am all for it
yeah as you guys know uh at the end of
july i was banned from twitter for
saying that vaccine mandates are coming
i'm pretty sure really i got that one
right elijah what what actually were the
two things that you said let's go ahead
and say them what are they going to do
come on i read the box of
of
paper masks and also stated the letter
from health and human services which
says that there are no true blind
studies that show the effectiveness of
masks to large-scale mitigate covid19
in many ways there's no large scale
double blinds and also that these normal
surgical mass that people are wearing
have warnings on the box that are saying
that you know basically they're not
going to be effective in mass use
through the use of kids using them
in order to stop the spread of any
serious viral load and and the reality
is i'm just reading letters from the
government agencies from the boxes and
i'm just reading that now youtube says
that's not true that's not medical
advice but i always say i mean
i'm probably more likely to trust the
health and human services which is
saying something
even that and probably the manufacturers
who can get sued of a mask rather than
some tech nerd who went to stanford that
lives in uh palo alto i mean that's just
me
i for one only trust sanjay gupta
because that guy knows what he's doing
uh all right let's let's start with some
video here uh we've got this elderly man
who's pretending to be president of the
united states joe biden listen to this
let's be clear
vaccination requirements should not be
another issue that divides us
that's why
we continue to battle the misinformation
that's out there
and companies and communities are
setting up there uh stepping up as well
to
combat these
the misinformation
southwest airlines
at the head of the pilot the head of the
pilots union and the ceo dismiss critics
who claim vaccination mandates
contributed to flight disruptions
school board members
religious leaders and doctors across the
country are fighting misinformation and
educating people about the importance of
vaccines
all these efforts are going to help us
continue moving the dial
to eliminate this disease
all right i like to i like to give
credit where credit is due uh he read
off the teleprompter pretty well there
jesse he doesn't want us to be divided
if we just do what he says we won't be
divided right come on
i don't know why you're dividing us dave
if you would just do what your lord and
master says we won't be divided do i
have to hit you again look it's i don't
want to hit you again but i'll hit you
again if you don't do what i say why are
you for my own good
this is this is beyond the creepiness of
the fact we have a half functional
president i realize we all make fun of
that now but have you actually thought
about that that's the commander-in-chief
the leader of the free world he is not a
fully functional adult and now it's
happened so long which just kind of
baked in the cake it's like oh that's
old joe that's the president that's the
president of the united states of
america that's one too
isn't this whole thing beyond creepy how
you're not allowed to discuss anything
except the vaccine no natural immunity
remember when they they started banning
hydroxychloroquine you're not allowed to
talk about ivermectin you're not allowed
to talk about sunshine you're not
allowed to talk about not being fat
anymore you're not allowed to talk about
anything only the vaccine anything else
is shouted down it doesn't take a
right-winger to think that's really
really creepy and something's off
how about herd immunity remember that
phrase we don't talk about herd immunity
anymore
now they just update all the uh
definitions of things to fit the current
climate so that when you talk about hurt
immunity now you're an insane person
because apparently that's not a thing
anymore
but sydney but sydney he said it right
there i mean he's basically saying you
know people like us we're spreading
misinformation you've got your on-air
partner elijah over there reading
statements i mean misinformation what
are you guys doing it's i mean i think
what my frustration is is that even if
you don't have the greatest grasp of
biology or how a lot of this stuff works
i freely admit i'm not an expert when it
comes to any of this but i go it's
really strange to me that we can't even
have a conversation about it that we're
really at a point where they go no no no
no discussion can go down whatsoever
because if you are talking about it and
it's contrary again to the narrative
then there's something wrong with that
excuse me and you must stop you must
stop and it must never happen like
really this thing that we've had
since the beginning of time in humans
which is natural immunity why is that
banned on instagram why can't you search
that term on instagram or even just why
is it the one elijah says that there's
no efficacy of masks in children why is
it that that gets wiped off the internet
this whole thing especially with biden
and it's like jesse says you know we
laugh about it because it's humiliating
but on a world stage it's so humiliating
that this is the leader of the free
world and you have to say the world
because what does that even mean anymore
it is i don't mean to interrupt but i
just have to point this out too just
piggybacking off what sydney just said
the social distancing thing
we've moved so far past that we don't
even laugh about that anymore appointed
i am can we just bring up how ridiculous
it is that the leader of the free world
and the most technological
technologically advanced country in the
world and the richest country in the
world got a virus and the solution was
stand six feet away from each other and
not only was that the solution to this
day you see it you're still standing in
footsteps in grocery stores across the
country that's something a toddler would
come up with just stand away from him
daddy then you'll be safe and yet this
is something the the most powerful
country in the world did as a matter of
policy it's insane right exactly you you
go to every you go to every airport and
they're jam-packed right now because of
flight cancellations we'll get to that
in a second and yet they've got signs
everywhere saying social distancing
which nobody's doing but elijah to that
point he even in that very statement
that he read he shared misinformation
when he started talking about southwest
which canceled thousands of flights this
week because we know that they were
protesting the vaccine mandates the the
ceo he also sort of lied about what the
ceo said because the ceo kind of said
that's what happened um but is it
possible that flights can only be
affected by weather if they're southwest
flights and not other flights because
that's basically that's basically what
joe's saying
yeah you know i think what it is is
we've come into a place where truth
matters so little that people pretty
much say whatever they want and i've
heard it said that the media and the
government have sort of become like a
father who has been out of a child's
life for 10 years and suddenly pops back
in and tries to pretend like they know
them and we're the child it's like dad
we are so we're decade apart we are way
beyond you we have grown up we have
grown past you we don't need you and
don't try to come back in my life
because you just quite frankly weren't
needed and i figured out how to go about
and so you're going to complicate things
and when they say you know the southwest
airlines were about uh you know i don't
know pilots being upset as upset about
what because when i see gadsden flags
hanging out of out of southwest plains
i'm like come tread on me daddy you know
i'm going who's daddy and who's treading
what is this is this about a two dollar
you know wage uh increase of course not
we're in the instrumental part of our
society where we are segregating people
i mean we are already seeing the
introduction of blood-based
passports internationally from the world
economic forum i mean they are talking
about bringing gattaca and these movies
to life putting taking our blood samples
using that as a direct input to give us
clarity to travel and to buy things
around the world and it's not just a
future idea i mean the largest banks in
in australia even the the grocery stores
um like woolworths and kohl's not to be
confused with american coals with the k
this with a c are are you know going to
be linking you know the same qr code
system for payment that they are for the
vax passport but yet are saying they
won't be linked together in whatever way
that that means i mean we are headed
towards an absolute tyrannical communist
regime and people
at least before they're gonna get
violent which they will
are at least protesting the only way
they know how and then they're being uh
dismissed by a half-present president i
could say this will spell nothing but
disaster and it's also humiliating like
jesse says it's humiliating that we've
come to accept this i haven't i'm still
laughing at these people and now i'm
getting pissed and i kind of want to see
more happen
yeah to your point by the way you're not
making up some alex jones crazy
conspiracy theory here about world
economic forum you just tweeted out the
video so we'll we'll link to it in the
description jesse you had a freaking
awesome twitter thread a couple days ago
about sort of the split that's happening
in the country and and how we have to
realign and it's it was sort of echoing
something i've been saying for a while
which is we've all just got to put our
differences aside right now and realize
that the communists and the marxists
they're here they're pretty much
everywhere in the media and big tech in
our political establishment and everyone
else has to put aside tax rates and
whatever else you're upset about
somebody with it's like fight for
america now or never can you just kind
of elaborate on that bit
yeah i mean the sappers are digging
underneath the walls and they're they're
banging down the gates as we speak and
we still have most of the right in
wanting to have a meeting about how tall
the hoa should allow the grass to be in
the front lawns i mean that's really
what we're doing these people are com we
are completely surrounded every single
cultural institution from sports to the
fbi to the military to half the religion
in this every cultural institution is
now taken over by marxists who think you
dave rubin you sydney watson you elijah
schaefer are not only evil these people
if they were legally allowed to do so
would throw you in prison right now not
10 years from now right now they would
throw you in prison so you can't talk
anymore and that's at a bare minimum and
yet we still have so much of the right
haggling over who should be a trump or
nationalists or libertarians or whatnot
there is nothing else that matters in
this world than stopping communists
right now in america that's why i'm an
anti-communist i'm not a libertarian i'm
not a republican i'm not a conservative
i because stopping these people is all
that matters and if we could stop him
tomorrow i would retire and just walk
away and you all work it out but instead
you get so much of this fighting on the
right now well actually governor
shouldn't ban the mandates because
that's not small government are you
people out of your mind it's not the
year 1900 it's the year 2021 and we
currently have the president of the
united states pointing to five ten
percent of the workforce and saying
you're fired because you won't do
something i want to do that's mao i mean
that's mao stuff and we're arguing over
the governor's shooter shouldn't that
every politician right now on the right
should be joining shields to protect the
people because the people are under
assault and we we can't even get our own
side on board with it drives me insane
yeah sydney i'll give you a last word on
that
i was just going to say i mean i don't
know why you're surprised jesse this has
been in action for a really really
really long time and you're also i feel
like and i know that you're completely
blackfield like me on this but you're
expecting governors and you're expecting
republicans to actually do something
other than line their own pockets come
on
come on no they know you're you're 100
right it's not that i'm expecting them
to it's i i know they're a bunch of you
yeah they are they're babies
i'm aware that we have a bunch of
eunuchs who lead us i am also aware
though that these losers can be whipped
into doing something decent i i know
we're not going to have all of them but
they can be whipped into doing something
decent if enough of us are screaming
will you do something you idiot yeah i
wanted to say that real fast that there
seems to be a lot of argument online
about um you know people are like this
government is going fascist i want to
remind you that most of your history
books were written by like some form of
communists at least sympathizers or
communists who are trying to get you to
think that fascists are in charge okay
sure we all agree come together nazi bad
etc i mean even that whole rhetoric to
focus on the nazis all the time is to
distract off of the people today that
are happening the fascists fought
communists communists are trying to
confuse people and make you think
they're fascists when reality they're
communists they're globalist communists
they are unilateral they have
infiltrated every institution you need
to call them out for what they are don't
get confused people go it's the same
side of this you know the same coin or
whatever no it's not these are
communists there's a way to defeat them
we will destroy them i'm not saying to
become fascist or something like that
but the way that you destroy somebody is
to figure out exactly who you're
fighting first
and until you realize this is not about
you know democratic socialists et cetera
no these are totalitarian democial
genocidal communists who will murder you
they will kill your family they will
jail you they will silence you they will
take whatever means necessary and like
jesse said the reason why things are are
heating up the reason why things are
getting more intense is because their
battle and their war is getting intense
and i'm sick of the and i'm sick of
pretending to be on the defense it is
time that we take the offense that's
where my mind's at
elijah dropping the black pills right
now we're gonna have to shift you to
some clown pills for this one because uh
terry mcauliffe who's just like one of
the worst sort of democrat swamp
creatures known to man he is running for
governor
in virginia and we've got a very short
clip of him that will perfectly
uh explain the hypocrisy of these
ridiculous politicians take a look
in addition it is a donald trump betsy
devos plan of moving money from public
to private i will never allow that as
governor that's why parents support me
and when you well your guys you're not
going to believe this he's really for
public education as you can see and he
just will not let those trump things
stand where people have choice but from
national review not only did mcauliffe
send at least four of his children to
the dc area potomac school in the 2000s
and 2010s where the annual thirty
thousand dollar tuition exceeds that of
most in-state public universities but he
and his wife invested heavily in shaping
their experience there jesse this is
shocking is it not that these people are
beyond hypocrites i can't believe it
well i'm stunned dave i have i had no
idea because i mean mao was definitely
starving when he was starving 70 million
of his own countrymen right i mean
stalin he was practically starving to
death when he
completely wiped out ukraine this is
communism
we keep bringing up the word but that's
what it is people act like well it's not
communism because there's a bunch of
rich people getting richer that's
communism that's the entire religion it
is a few people who run the whole place
while they wipe everything out and again
these people are not hypocrites i mean
they are but they're not
it's not that they're hypocrites it's
that they feel as if they are a higher
class the people who run this country
all share the same three characteristics
now no love of country they're
completely divorced from reality because
they go right from universities into
government they live in dc they have no
idea how real people live and lastly
they genuinely believe they are these
blue bloods and you are the plebs and
they should rule over you and it's not
it's not that they're hypocrites they're
part of the priest class they of course
get the fancy communion wine you peasant
if you're lucky will be allowed to sit
in the pews and for them that's not
hypocrisy that's simply the natural
order of things sydney do you kind of
admire it i keep asking all my guests
this like do you kind of admire their
ability to be hypocrites even though i
get jesse's points but just to just say
anything that is completely uh in
conflict with the way they actually live
and just get away with it time and time
again and do it completely shamelessly
yeah i mean it's kind of impressive that
they don't hold themselves to any
standards but you know it's funny
because i know that i think you three
would disagree with me on this when i
looked into what he'd said i guess i
don't really find it that hypocritical
in the sense that he's paying the 30 000
per kid whereas i think that what we're
talking about here is that the
government in some way will be
subsidizing and funding poorer students
to go to private schools i went to a
private school i really admit that and
my parents paid i think someone in the
realm of 20 grand a year to send me
there but it was because they were in a
financial position to do so and that's
why they're private schools that's the
differentiation between government
schools and private schools if they're
being government-funded then aren't they
now government-funded private schools
like i don't know maybe i'm wrong here
maybe i don't understand the the topic
that well but i feel like on this one i
kind of get where he's coming from a
little bit well i think i think the uh
go ahead no say who funds the government
like a lot of this is a little more
complicated elijah but yeah i know but
but the taxpayer what it's saying is
that you're paying into a flag
yes you are it's like social security so
you're paying over time like assuming
when you had kids and they grow up and
they're going into these high schools a
lot of this isn't necessarily school
choice even for elementary schools a lot
of this is specifically in terms of
charter schools and public well which is
still public but public high schools and
in in private high schools this is where
the main argument is coming down there
are some other arguments in primary
school but it comes into middle and and
secondary education and the interesting
thing though is that it's just like
social security which is you know you're
paying into but will probably dry up
before you can actually tap into it
there is an understanding that the
government has allotted a certain amount
of spending to be made for your child
because of the money that you pay into
the tax system through property taxes
etc and so what the point of this is is
that people are saying well if there's a
certain granted amount of my money that
i'm paying into the government that's
being set aside to pay for my child's
education overall long term believing
that i'll pay into it can i not use that
money to put my kid not just in a
private school but in a school that i
believe that they should be into this
goes into districting putting them into
a different district this goes into
charter schools allowing schools to be
partially privately funded through
grants and also to the federal
government they're not just saying hey
this is private they're even looking
like can we get donors and use tax
credits can you give me a not even money
can you give me a tax deduction so i can
use that money to to put into my kids
private education because i don't want
to pay the taxes for them to go to a
public school giving people the choice
with their own money how they spend
their taxes is really the argument when
you get down to it and how that money is
allocated where it's saying no there's
no other way you need to give this
certain amount of money and everyone
needs to be equal and go to the same
school yeah i get that and where it's at
but now i understand that and in the
sense that that makes sense what you
just said makes total sense if people
want to actually have a decision making
or they want to actually participate in
the decision making for where their
money goes in relation to the education
of their children but if we're just
talking about like are you a hypocrite
because you send your kid to a
private school and you pay this amount
of money out of your own pocket
you're paying that in addition to the
taxes that you're already paying for the
other students to go to pri to public
schools rather i just guess that i look
at this and i go i don't really
understand like
look he said some other jack stuff about
education freely fully admit that when
it comes to this one i'm like i don't
really i don't know i don't really see
well i think i think the other layer of
hypocrisy is that he doesn't want to
instill the economic policies that would
allow anyone else to have the 30 grand
that he's paying per kid
on top of everything else but actually
we've got we've got a theme of sort of
hypocrisy or something much worse than
hypocrisy going here uh this next video
this is ben and jerry you know these
hippie 60s ice cream people they did an
absolutely debacle i mean a true
disaster of an interview with axios
we've got about a minute of it right
here disagree with the israeli
government policy why not just stop
sales completely well i disagree with
the u.s policy
we couldn't stop selling in the u.s i
think it's fine to
be involved with
a country to be to be a citizen of a
country
and to protest
some of the some of the country's
actions
and
that's essentially
what we're doing in terms of israel we
hugely support israel's right to exist
but we are against a particular policy
you guys are big proponents of voting
rights why do you still sell ice cream
in georgia texas abortion bans
why are you still selling there
i don't know
i mean i mean it's a it's an interesting
question
i don't know what
what that would accomplish
we're working on those issues of voting
rights and
i don't know i you know i mean i think
you ask a really good question and i
think
i'd have to sit down and think about it
for a bit
he'd have to sit down and think about it
for a bit he's half bernie sanders half
larry david we should have put the curb
music in there but it's just such a
perfect such a perfect example about how
these people don't think through
anything and by the way guys you're not
going to believe this those hippies
those peace loving progressive socialist
hippies they sold ben and jerry's uh
about 15 20 years ago for roughly 350
million dollars to unilever one of the
largest corporations in the entire world
but again is is hypocrisy calling it
hypocrisy is not quite enough is it
jesse
no it's not but they're they're just par
for the course i mean you brought up
that they're huge bernie people and
bernie's a great example of this what
did he have three houses while espousing
all that communist crappy throws out
there but again this is not it's not
hypocrites that's what socialism is
that's what communism is it always works
out that way it's always for the
peasants right it's always for the ones
they should rule over it's never it's
never for them they all want the finer
things in life they just believe they
should rule and deny you the finer
things in life because they are the gods
that will hand out the economy or hand
out the equality that they believe the
world should do that's that's that's why
the whole thing has been such a joke
it's why it's rejected all the time it's
why it fails all the time because nobody
nobody can take in that much power and
not want more of it or that much money
and not want more of it it fails all the
time for a reason and those guys are a
great example
sydney this kind of reminded me of the
sanjay gupta joe rogan thing from this
week that when basically these people
who are treated with kid gloves all the
time in media appearances when they have
to do something a little more long form
and i doubt that axios is like the most
difficult place you know that woman
she's perfectly fine obviously but like
i don't think this was like they walked
in thinking this would be the hardest
thing ever that they completely fold
because they really don't know what
they're talking about which is exactly
what happened to sanjay with rogan i
know and it's you know i don't know if
you guys are like me but i get the worst
secondhand embarrassment watching this
stuff because like that pause and he
goes i don't know oh my god i thought my
heart was going to explode it's so
awkward to listen to but i mean you're
right at the end of the day if you
receive no pushback on anything that you
ever say out in the world or ever put
out into the world as a general rule
when you do come into contact with
somebody who questioned you even and she
was being very nice that interviewer
just by the way she's being very very
polite very nice uh if you're if you
still can't answer a question then it
really goes to show that hey you haven't
thought through your position which i
think when it comes to ice cream people
i'm not really surprised by that in any
capacity because they do slacktivism
it's that thing where oh let's put uh
colin kaepernick on a on a ice cream tub
and that's going to be the end of it
let's make our you know millions in
sales we'll manipulate the crap out of
the population then we take our money
home and we sit up on you know in our
nice little house away from all the
plebs and we go hahaha look we did a
good thing for the day so i don't know i
mean i'm not surprised by these people
being as dumb as uh two short planks
because that's kind of what they do but
they are really good at manipulating us
i think that's what's funny about it the
people who buy this i pity them elijah
the longer i do whatever it is that i do
here the more it's obvious to me that my
old former team pretty much everybody
and there's almost no exclusions to this
it's not necessarily that they're bad
people although there are some bad ones
at the top but pretty much everybody
just does not think about anything they
just think the world exists because it
should exist and it's the way they want
it to be and they have to keep you know
replicating it to be the way they want
it to be but they just don't think about
anything so then you get asked like the
most basic question
and and you completely freeze up
yeah i mean this comes into world of
view i mean when you think the world's
been around for billions and billions of
years it always was and it always will
be then there's not much incentive to
really think about things it's just to
keep things going and if you think the
world's just a machine and a mechanism
with no purpose then you don't need to
have a purpose you just need to react
and so that's where world view largely
comes into how society forms and these
people are just not awake they don't
they don't process information in any
tangible way and dave this makes me miss
i'll tell you this so this is sort of a
white pill for me because
you know this makes me miss the college
wars of like 2016 2017 those are the
good old days oh yeah you were right in
the thick of that i mean i remember
going to protest i was laughing right
now i was watching some old protest
footage
going out there you know asking people
you know about donald trump and people
telling me donald trump was hitler's
nephew and asking them like i thought
they were joking and then being like no
no i he is and you're like
okay so apparently
being mentally ill is no longer a
disability it's a common trait of our
current society and so i you know i mean
we remember that and these people were
stupid and they've learned to shut up
they've shut up and they've given their
mouthpieces to the forefront they've
become militant because we mocked them
we made fun of them and the sad part is
as they didn't learn
to become smarter they are not trying to
become smarter like jesse said because
they're not hypocrites because they're
dumb
the people in power have just realized
that it's not about using these dumb
people at the forefront anymore they've
gone full military industrial complex
communist by using now policy and using
the government to do their battles for
them like the days of the brown shirts
and believing ben and jerry's is going
to accomplish leftist goals is totally
out the window nobody even relies on
these people anymore because they really
don't know what the hell they're talking
about and unfortunately in some ways
they're kind of victims of their own
ignorance all right let me let me let me
monologue on that for a brief moment
here sorry sorry let me take this for a
second because i get emails sometimes to
my show from former communists and
they'll write in and every single one of
them to a man or two women will say
it is group think it is a hive mind and
i a long time ago i did some stupid
youtube video it doesn't matter where i
went to the brett kavanaugh protest and
i went undercover even though i stick
out like a sore thumb none of that
matters it's not it's still on youtube
but there was a moment where one of
these communists came up to me because
she had followed my social media and
said hey this jessie kelly uh he's he's
not really one one of us and then she
says it's still in the video she says i
always thought it was so odd she says do
not talk to this clown and then she
starts a chant that nobody joins in do
not talk to this clown do not talk to
this clown and i thought it was the
oddest thing like what are you chanting
what is wrong with you but i i thought
it was really actually a really
revealing moment that's how these people
are it is a total
hive mind they don't think it is the
hive mind it's why whether it's barack
obama or bed and jerry or anybody sanjay
gupta or any of them if you actually can
pin them down and ask one or two probing
questions just that deep i mean we're
talking air force deep just that deep
nothing they just cave they either cave
or they lash out fascists racist that
kind of stuff i want people to know when
they do that it's not because they think
you're that it's because that's their
trained response from the hive mind when
challenged because they don't have any
depth at all none of them do
you're so right i mean most of my
audience has seen this already but
there's a video that i did from
university of new hampshire like five
years ago and they're chanting and
they're screaming and they've got noise
makers and the whole thing and every
time they start chanting and they would
do it they would have a bell to signal
when who was supposed to chant what
their switch at and i would literally
get in i mean you can see the video on
youtube i would walk up to them get a
few feet away from them and i would try
to look them in the eye and say hey if
you've got a problem with anything i'm
saying or you disagree with me please
let me know but you're just mindlessly
chanting you're not really getting
anything gross and they won't even look
at you at that point because they don't
this is to elijah's point they don't
even see you as a human at that point
which if you start not seeing people as
human uh you might start doing some bad
things to them uh but speaking of bad
things let's finish up with uh what's
going on in australia uh and uh we've
got some video here
there's a lot of craziness happening in
australia and i've been talking about it
all week that in italy and in france and
across europe there's all these
anti-vaccine protests but for some
reason guys it's not on cnn they're not
showing this on msnbc that people can
stand up against the government couple
quotes here from the bbc uh sydney
exited lockdown after new south wales
state reached a double-dose vaccination
target for over 16 year olds more
restrictions will ease when over 80
percent of over 16 year olds are fully
vaccinated currently over 90 percent
have received the first dose and
australia has previously adhered to a
coveted elimination strategy and this
remains the objective in some states so
there's a million videos basically of
all over australia where they are
arresting people for walking their dogs
people just walking out to the market
the police officers choking people in
the name of health
i mean irony is truly dead uh sydney i
just mentioned sydney so uh you are
australian what the hell is going on
over there uh
you know
people i think people are shocked
because they always have this perception
of australia that aussies are these like
very right-wing sort of larrican redneck
kind of people and i suppose to some
extent they are but there's also this
reliance on the government over there
that drove me crazy when i lived there
which is part of the reason why i left
um but i'm not really shocked by what
i'm seeing because aussies and i i've
said this a thousand times and i'll keep
saying it aussies value security over
freedom and the problem is that when
that is your primary mentality it means
that anything that the government says
is good for you you're inclined to
believe so it's really like again i mean
when you consider i don't know if you
guys heard but in the northern territory
which is arguably one of the most like
relaxed places um
in the entirety of the country it's
melbourne and sydney that are really
really really bad but in northern
territory if you don't get vaccinated uh
in particular workplaces they'll the
government will find you five thousand
dollars so we're at a point where
they've just reached like apex stupidity
and the people it said they can't do
anything to fight back
they're totally disarmed
jesse you
yeah jesse you talk a lot about the
media i mean the fact that none of these
protests and we're seeing massive
protests across europe the fact that
none of them and i'm not exaggerating
they're never covered on mainstream
media in america that that's a signal to
us right like it's like oh don't you
find out about that because then you
might start doing it here it tells you
all you need to know and i still
remember david i'm sure you do too right
after the election they actually ran a
poll it ties right into this uh they
pulled democrats what do you think the
biggest issue in america is today and by
a mile i think it was double the next
closest thing by a mile for democrats in
the united states of america the most
important issue was tackling white
supremacy now i've lived everywhere i'm
40 years old i've lived all over this
country i've never met one white
supremacy doesn't even exist in any
organized form in this country and if
there's even a whiff that you are one
your whole life's destroyed and the fbi
will probably knock on your door so this
is something that does not exist and yet
half the country because of the media
thinks it's the number one priority of
the nation now translate that to how
they're going to handle all these
massive protests you already heard the
president of the united states uh
southwest airlines said it it wasn't a
walkout it was the weather when it was
sunshine and clear skies and no wind and
things like that in florida there now
because you can't cover up the pain
that's coming you can't cover up ground
beef and gas and eggs and baby formula
and all the other financial pain that's
coming now they're going to lie about
the why just mark my word the why is
what they're live unforeseen
circumstances oh oh it's foreseen but
they'll lie a lot now
elijah at that point have they just
created the perfect system here of lying
well they've done it sort of everywhere
that no matter what happens you can
always blame it on the unvaccinated you
can always blame it on the
insurrectionists and the white
supremacists and all of the people who
have actually no power whatsoever
yeah i know i mean absolutely and when
you think about all of this
it's a basically a perfect recipe
because they control so much of
information to essentially set whatever
narrative they want to and even if
people don't agree with it it doesn't
matter because they're so demoralized
they won't even fight it
i i don't even think people want to
think right now and i've been arguing
with people people are so in denial
about what's happening in the world i'm
watching people that i wished were
standing up to the injustices in the
world like you know i'd say to anybody
who uh gets the vaccine that you didn't
want to get it and it's against your
moral conscience and you do something
anything especially a medical decision
out of peer pressure you know
you will lose your ability to fight
something even harder if this is where
you give up if this is where you
are unable to resist what makes you
think you're going to be able to stand
up to tyranny when things even get
tougher it's like you so you would
sacrifice your life for somebody that
would be discriminated against because
you have some weird romantic
romanticization of you know world war ii
and that you would give your life for
the jews so the nazis wouldn't take them
bro you wouldn't even give up a 17 an
hour job that you hate to do something
that you didn't want to do and yet you
would give up your life oh please give
me a break i mean it's like you put on a
mask voluntarily and i'm not being
patronizing or pretentious here i'm just
saying like
you know the people that i see that are
you know getting vaccines when they
don't want to get them and they're
feeling like they're being forced to get
them which is different than people who
want to get them right there's a big
difference there um i see those are the
same people who even when they didn't
have to wear a mask were still wearing
one because the sign asked them to and
it's the people that what it is people
have slowly not stood up to the tyranny
as it's occurred as it's happened and
slowly they've made decisions that have
broken their conscience that have went
against their their ability to resist
and the government knew that from shut
down from two weeks to shutdowns to
extensions to social distancing to masks
to now mandates people don't have the
will in them to fight anymore on a mass
scale and so yeah they can do whatever
they want now of course the the vocal
minority it isn't the it isn't the
silent majority it's actually the vocal
minority
remember most wars and things were
fought with like one to three percent of
any given population we're standing up
and going look we drew the line a long
time ago and if you're listening to this
and you've already given it enough what
is it going to take for you to draw the
line to say no enough is enough i'm not
giving into this i'm not fighting uh oh
i'm not going with the curve i'm going
to join the fight i'm going to resist
and if this isn't what it takes then
we're not on the same team and i'm sorry
you will not be there for me and i
cannot rely on you and it's breaking
apart families it's breaking apart
states it's breaking apart countries
more importantly it's dividing the world
but i gotta say choose which side you're
on today because if you don't the choice
is made for you no well said the least
we can all do is just stop participating
in the live because they are just going
to keep lying all right i got 30 seconds
for each of you give me some version of
a white pill if you believe there is a
white pill in all of this or a silver
lining i think there were a couple
moments this week that actually did seem
kind of good their their overt lying you
know everything that saki says is now
such so obviously a lie that's got to be
red pilling people cnn accidentally had
two doctors on saying that we shouldn't
have vaccine mandates for flights like
the the sanjay gupta rogan thing like
there's a couple moments that seem like
they're waking up people that's kind of
my white pill of the week kelly any hope
oh yeah absolutely hope this southwest
airlines thing is not small this is the
start of something big this is the start
of a massive nationwide protest it is
the start of the end of the bind
administration it is a big big big deal
it's really important we don't need a
majority we don't even need a a big
minority 10 of this country chooses to
push back and not participate they will
bring this regime to its knees and i
think it's happening
cindy
um i really like that there's a bunch of
police forces around the country that
are actually not participating anymore
in the vax mandate stuff and i'll say
this much about back home in australia
i'm noticing that more and more and more
people are getting pissed off and
they're actually willing to do something
about what the government's doing and
that makes me really thankful and really
happy
yeah even here in crazy la our police
chief is not enforcing it so i mean if
there's ever if there's ever a sign for
hope all right elijah bring us home and
then i'm gonna finish up for a few
minutes without you guys yeah i would
just say that hard times are creating
strong men and i'm watching a lot of
people email me every day that are
giving up a guy gave up his job at
border patrol even broke up with his
fiancee he said i've watched your show
shows like this and i realized i needed
to to become the man that i need to be
and the country needs strong men it
needs women who believe in those men and
families together and the fact that it's
unfortunately hard times aren't fun but
there's a lot of men who are responding
to the call and it's giving me great
hope because these are men that i know
will be able to rely on when things
become almost
impossible well i got nothing better to
do than save the world i suspect you
guys don't either so i thank you for
joining me and our work is cut out for
us
thanks boss thank you for having us
all right so i have actually no idea
what happened with our live stream
capabilities there so sorry for the
delay hopefully we can work all that out
connor you're you're working throughout
the weekend okay you're gonna get in
there get in the computer and we're
gonna miniaturize you and put you in the
processor or something like that uh
anyway i really do think there's hope i
really do think there's hope there's
little glimmers that's all we've needed
remember last week when i was saying ah
it's hard to see the thing well now
there's some glimmers so so just do
what you can do or just enjoy yourself
for the weekend how about that just
forget the whole freaking thing and eat
some good food and listen to some great
music and do something that you enjoy
that is also pretty darn good all right
have a great weekend everybody and i'll
see you on monday
you